the the authentic self is the is the is
the conscious experience of the of an
ecstatic sense of urgency and Eagle is
passion that is one with and synonymous
with the energy and intelligence that
initiated the creative process and just
the simple definition is I say that the
the easiest way to understand what the
evolutionary impulse is first to do is
we realize that when a human being
experiences the sexual impulse that's
the best that's the biological it's a
biologically felt command to procreate
and the sexual impulses really
synonymous with the Big Bang with the
fundamental urge to create or to become
in this case is to procreate our own
species so whenever a human being
experiences the ecstatic urgency that is
the sexual impulse we are experiencing
the the big bang but we're experiencing
at the lowest level human beings are the
only species that experience an urge to
innovate and to create things that are
new there's no other species that
experience this a compulsion to innovate
and create things that are new and of
course this started millions of years
ago but now we know that the the our
capacity to innovate and create has
reached on an exponential speed but if
we ever meet a truly inspired or
passionate or gifted or talented
engineer artist poet scientists a
spiritual teacher public servant but an
individual who is passionately committed
to creating something new in their
presence one will feel a sense of
ecstatic urgency I must do this and and
the all these in jersey all these
individuals are committed to to making
manifest these these these these
potentials that are just that are just
at the verge of entering and entering
into the present and they see them and
they feel them you know they see and
they feel these potentially and they
feel that ecstatically committed to give
it to giving them birth so d The
Ecstatic urgency that we feel as the
sexual impulse and the ecstatic urgency
that deeply creative geniuses experience
is is that the highest level experience
as the spiritual impulse and the
spiritual impulse is the urge towards
consciousness the desire to become more
conscious to felt or the mysteriously
felt urge to become more conscious I
must become more conscious I feel I have
to I must and we say well where does
that come from in in in a secular
culture where our values are
fundamentally materialistic and
narcissistic where could such a strong
compulsion comes from well if it comes
it comes from the very process that made
it possible for us to have the
experience right now so the leading edge
of that original intention to create a
material universe is when a human being
experiences this is mysteriously fell
compulsion towards consciousness I must
evolve level of consciousness I must
become more conscious so that experience
is what the authentic self is the higher
we is when is when any two or more
individuals awaken to the the
consciousness of this of this authentic
self in the same time and in the same
place because the authentic self isn't
the the ER the urge to become more
consciousness this dispassionately felt
ecstatic sense of urgency is egoless so
when I I would awaken to that state of
consciousness and that that that
future-oriented compulsion that's not
personal and you would awaken to that
dead future-oriented a compulsion that's
not personal we experience what's called
intersubjective non-duality
intersubjective means between subjects
it's the shared space between
individuals and what we experience in
this state is that is there are no ego
boundaries so there would be a sense
that there's literally nothing between
us that we are in fact one being one
consciousness while at the same time and
in the same space recognizing and
appreciating the fact that we are
actually two different people and it's a
paradox and it's a contradiction but in
the experience we experience both at the
same time and and in the experience
there there isn't any contradiction it's
simply true that we are
absolutely one and the same time we are
different and this makes it possible for
us to to share a sense of intimacy and
communion and Trust and also creative
engagement that's absolutely impossible
in any other kind of circumstance